the clark county test positivity rate
now at 6.2 percent
as these numbers climb health officials
urging the community to take
basic safety precautions especially if
you are
unvaccinated as kate houston reports
even those who have received their shots
shouldn't throw caution to the wind
in hindsight that's the one thing i
would have done is i would have wore
a mask 63-year-old peter gerali is
battling covid19
but unlike most recent positive cases
durali and his wife
are vaccinated i was surprised i was
hopeful you know they were going to come
back and say it's negative you just have
a cold
but i i kind of expected it to be
positive
because i felt really bad durali
believes he contracted the virus while
at a recent golden knights game
the giralis say like many people there
they weren't wearing a mask
just wear a mask don't you know people
are going to stare at you or they're
going to
say something to you and it might get
even out of hand
as we've seen but just wear a mask
health officials agree
especially as case numbers rise the need
for testing has gone up dramatically
dr jonathan bhaktari with e-7 health
says while durali's situation is rare
it highlights the importance of getting
the vaccine to reduce the severity of
symptoms
and continuing to test for the virus the
testing that we're seeing
really is more in the younger population
and we're
obviously the people who have been
unvaccinated until vaccination rates
drastically increase
dr bhattari highly recommends people
continue to get tested
to prevent even more spread of the virus
they actually need to think about their
loved ones and other people
so get tested even if you think you're
going to be okay get tested so you can
quarantine and not infect others kate
houston
8 news now giraldi said his symptoms
started as a cold
quickly developed to a fever loss of
taste and smell
and fatigue his wife marianne also
vaccinated but
did not get kobit 19.